[Music]
chaos and downright panic as 9-1-1 calls
started pouring in following a crash
that killed nine people over the weekend
good evening and thanks for joining us
at six i'm denise valdez and i'm brian
loftis and tonight we're hearing the
panic from witnesses after that horrific
crash at commerce in cheyenne happening
on saturday so a driver who was speeding
ran a red light killing a family of
seven that driver and his passenger also
died and another driver was seriously
hurt victoria saha joins us live from
the newsroom with what these witnesses
reported at the scene victoria
denise and brian from what we know
already and now hearing these 9-1-1
calls this was a chaotic and
heart-wrenching scene witnesses calling
dispatch urging them to hurry you can
hear the fear in their voices
oh peace
[Music]
in total this crash involved six
vehicles erlina zacharias lost seven of
her family members four children two
stepsons and her brother the ages range
from five to 35 years old she says they
were coming home from the park reporting
from the newsroom victoria zaha live
local now